in just over three weeks the cdc
eviction moratorium will end in recent
reports show nearly 200 000 nevada
households
are at risk for eviction a news now
reporter kate houston spoke to the legal
aid center of southern nevada
which is working around the clock to
help tenants understand their rights in
this process
families are just really struggling
right now and so we've had an
unprecedented
volume of calls from tenants requesting
our help
taylor altman is an attorney with the
legal aid center of southern nevada
she says it's important for tenants to
understand that if they receive a notice
from their landlord
they need to file an answer in court
even if they've applied for rental
assistance even if they've given the cdc
declaration to their landlord
they should definitely go ahead and file
that with the court you know to make
sure that they get a hearing
and they can present their side of the
story and any defenses they might have
to eviction
when filing tenants who have a notice
for non-payment of rent
can also take part in the new eviction
mediation program
a neutral third party will help the
landlord and tenant reach some kind of
resolution
on back rent in that case they might be
able to avoid court
altogether so the mediation program is
is excellent and i would recommend that
tenants
you know seriously consider that option
for those that have exhausted
all options and need to leave the legal
aid center understands the housing
market is tight right now
especially if a tenant has an eviction
on their record
they can call us and we can see if this
is something we could potentially
help them seal and so future landlords
would not be able to see those cases and
it wouldn't prejudice them in their
housing search
the legal aid center is helping tenants
fill out court documents and answering
questions they may have
attorney consultations are available for
those with more complex
cases kate houston 8 news now the cdc
eviction moratorium will expire on
december 31st while the legal aid center
is unsure if there will be an extension
they are hopeful the cdc and federal
government will act soon